différence fondamentale entre le bassin
sanitaire pascal final c'est qu'il ya
toujours la possibilité notre équipe
n'est pas vacciné de se faire tester
certes assez frais pour pouvoir accéder
un événement un établissement recevant
du public rentré dans un bar ou dans un
restaurant nous avons décidé avec le
président de la république qu'un projet
de loi sera soumis au parlement début
janvier notamment pour transformer le
pass sanitaire en passe vaccinale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il n'y aura pas d'impact de la troisième
dose pour le pass sanitaires c'est à
dire que si vous avez votre pass annie
terre que vous ayez comme une alliée
prendre votre rappel ou non je garderai
de bénéfices du pass samedi quand et du
15 décembre le pass annie terre pour les
plus de 65 ans ne sera plus actif si le
rappelle n'a pas été fait dans un délai
de sept mois après l'infection ou après
la dernière injection
et à compter du 15 janvier ce hassani
terre de tous les autres publics c'est à
dire des français âgés de 18 à 64 ans ne
sera plus actif si le rappelle n'a pas
été fait dans ce délai